what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today joined by
my co-host John how are you I am
enjoying listening to the the really
rich baritone of your voice right now
how are you good I sound like Michael
win God
get that perfect shot man oh yeah I
gotta get sick more I'm in recovery mode
guys but we got some exciting news
exciting reports here rumors I'm seeing
it all over social media right now I saw
it on comicbook.com as well I was like
Wow them I wonder if this is actually
true we got information about Captain
America 4 New World Order and of course
Thunderbolts and how this is all setting
up more mutants and specifically a man
with claws oh no
that's the joke I was gonna well I'd be
into the hilarious joke the audience is
laughing laboriously due to my joke mine
oh oh dead Deadpool from X-Men Origins
stop it Michael wincott commands
anyway leave a like people here we go
here we go here we go so here's the
basic report of what's going on do you
remember an eternals how um after Cersei
saved the day there was Tiamat the the
celestial poking up to the sky
apparently that's gonna be in Ireland
now all right cool and that people are
inhabiting it how I don't know how loud
how do they convert that to an island
they hollowed it out just use the entire
body cavity because like you just have
like a dome and a palm I actually do
have a theory as though what kind of
people might be inhabiting it and by
saying it like that you probably already
guess what my theory is going with that
President Ross he will be General
Thunderbolt Ross will not be president
Ross good for him yeah good for him he's
been working his way up the ladder he's
been trying really hard for a while they
want something from that Island which is
they they have the rare metal adamantium
with that you know comes all kinds of
territorialism people feeling like
they're being invaded and taken
advantage of you know it's kind of like
how the Americas were found what are you
talking about well you know how there
were like people just living here
enjoying their life we were all living
on a big hand ah they needed us to come
and show them how to make the big hand
work for that came in and said we want
the gold you got here and the gold now
being adamantium see it's commentary
political commentary New World Order you
get it oh my God Marvel's woke but this
will also tie into Thunderbolts the last
two films out of phase five are gonna be
Captain America and World Order and
Thunderbolts the other rumor is going
around is that the island is actually
going to be called ganosha which as many
of you guys know is a famous island from
uh the X-Men Comics it's actually I
think it's in dark Phoenix at one point
right it is magnetic
yeah yeah I think it is but yeah Magneto
is like very much associated with the
porn who's like running ganosha not
saying he's going to be in this but it
could be a setup for what's to come for
that so yeah the Thunderbolts will
reportedly be taking place at least
somewhat over there this team of
dreaming Celestial Island place that
people inhabit as well this is obviously
going to be setting up a lot for what's
to come for phase five most obviously if
this is true it's a direct tie-in to
X-Men it feels like every other film
we're getting closer and closer to
directly tying it in I know we got
Deadpool three coming but they've
already established it that's going to
be taking place before Logan so perhaps
that's still taking place within the fox
Universe timeline itself not exactly our
main MCU timeline regardless I think
this is a really cool setup and with it
being an island that's going to be
inhabited I'm wondering if the theory is
actually going to finally be coming true
of that whole thing with the dream and
Celestial omitting some kind of energy
that creates the mutagine or activates
immunogene that looks what if in fact
the people living there are indeed
already mutants you know Sean what do
you think about this thought process I'm
having that would be crazy I think it
would still be little abrupt given no no
John I don't care about it I think Sam
Wilson is Captain America I care about
mutants yes right and we have a whole
founded X-Men Colony right here they've
all got powers and costumes and planes
and stuff it's gonna be awesome I like
this as a concept and I'm excited to be
surprised by what it actually turns out
to be I mean it's gonna be 2024 this
movie's coming out unless they move it
so you know they can't use the X-Men yet
or cast new ones yet so yeah I don't
know 25 yeah yes and that will be when
phase six starts yeah so it makes what
we see here you know won't be able to
visually give us the entire realized
X-Men so you know I'm tempering
expectations but I think it's smart to
use Tiamat and I think it's interesting
I mean adamantium is a terrestrial metal
as of the comics but I think it could be
interesting if they're implying that
maybe some sort of celestial
intervention further legitimizing the
eternals might have created both a
reaction that could have sparked the X
Gene to awaken in but also could have
you know created some kind of adamantium
here like I think at least for what it's
doing for Captain America and the
Thunderbolts it's a really cool idea uh
for what it means for the overall X-Men
I'm not like oh my God if Wolverine's
about to show up I hope he does I think
he should I think he should people like
that I think someone should have a baby
and then what will you call him Logan
looks up Shameless
X 24. I mean some people were also
thinking that it might be cooler if they
instead of making a ganosha that they
made it the character forgive me if I'm
pronouncing this wrong I've only read
the name krakowa which is essentially is
a mutant but an island island mutant if
you've seen avatar The Last Airbender
you know those kind of characters are
awesome words it's an island no it's a
turtle you know that's kind of the same
basic concept right there yeah which
would be a neat way to go about it I
like what it's setting up for adamantium
because if you look at Black Panther
wakanda forever which set the stage for
the governments around the world all
wanting vibranium as like the ultimate
power source adamantium arguably could
be stronger at least maybe that's what
the government's even thinking
themselves so this would actually fall
in line with everything that we have
been setting up maybe not as overtly or
as obvious but that would be uh the
right direction I think to go after
phase four then if you're ending phase
five we got something better than
adamantium we need to get the leader
back in here so we can go extract that
oh yeah World War Hulk [ __ ] yeah
and then get this man an adamantium
Shield yeah yeah [ __ ] like that yeah I
won then you would have a Thunderbolts
movie that would be very sort of suicide
squad-esque and come with a good sort of
moral quandary at the center of it that
then maybe Captain America is able to
sway some of them away from versus you
know others who will further uh hold
tight hold faster you mean like the
Thunderbolts are trying to get this
adamantium [ __ ] and they realize like oh
no but if we give this over to president
Red Hulk yes
really bad this could be really bad and
also people just live here now
apparently and have a whole society and
we shouldn't maybe just like trample
through their Village as much like in
The Suicide Squad it just kill people
wantingly why I'm excited for this is
not because of the actual movie itself
but because of what they're setting up
for other movies down the road Marvel
you continue to do what you do best yeah
I can keep me questioning what's Captain
America gonna do while the nations of
the world argue over adamant that is an
interesting precedent to suffer him if
he is there to defend the people of Timo
to whatever the I live I don't know if
the arms can call Kenosha or not but if
he is there to defend those people it is
a nice reversal on the whole thing
especially with him being called Captain
America yeah the kind of commentary
sticking up for the people who are about
to be colonized and hey I mean
ganosa is in the Indian Ocean team what
is in the Indian Ocean there's enough
here to suggest that that's probably
what it will be down the line I think
this will be the early stages they'll
find that people are living there and
that's that'll be it and then event
actually it'll be like a Haven that's
all like cool and blade runnery but not
yeah it'll be a cyberpunk hand that are
living on yeah it will have to be I'm
like the have what's the surface area on
this thing how how much of a city could
we don't know how you form a city I
don't understand Hollow it out it makes
no sense I mean Tiamat wakes up at
certain points in the comics like this
question we're gonna do about that see
how they live here
yeah it makes me go wait a minute how is
any of this gonna work please
acknowledge but also here
any tricky decision just make it X-Men
and you're good all right guys well what
do you think about these plot reveals if
they are true do they excite you do you
care do you think it's all [ __ ] if
your thoughts down below it's all true
guys subscribe
I got this we're so close like subscribe
and send us
dude you got the most Italian name at
the patreon page I think it's both of us
yeah both of us I think appreciate that
we're both part Italian Greg's more
Italian than me it's often something we
argue about and he holds in my face as a
sign of dominance but you you're more
Italian than the both of us that's what
I love about you Gabe I hope you're at
least a little bit Italian so this shout
out works but more than that I hope that
you are having a lovely holiday season I
assume that you're a Catholic and that
you're you know feeling guilty while
also trying to be as generous as
possible to your loved ones you're as
generous as possible to us you could be
Asian and uh oh goodness he could be you
could be Asian in which case dominantly
an Asian name John oh wow well this is
awkward hey Italian Asian I just hope
you're doing well that's that's all I
care about
I I love you and I'm pleased to have you
still stick around 2020 yeah kick ass
[Music]